okay so Evan I mean app inventer really
is our our project to democratized
mobile technology and it's a vision that
anybody you know even kids or anybody
who has no Technical Training can really
start using this technology to be
empowered in what's become a world that
is now full of generative Ai and full of
all sorts of devices and we now been
working on it since what 2010 just about
yeah right and then before that it went
it had about six years of development at
Google that started right after 2006
right after the iPhone came out and then
Google moved it to MIT and we've been
expanding it and modifying it since then
and now we have what how many how many
users we have actually just last week we
had 20 million users of ai2 which is our
Flagship that I think is probably mit's
largest impact certainly educational
technology time and we've got a small
team that's doing
it I mean for me what happens with App
Inventor there was an original Vision
when mobile phones came out and people
said wow that's really really
interesting and it's really a thing and
now we're we're sort of in a new place
we're in a new place having to do with
generative
Ai and it's it's as if uh there was an
expansion of possibilities but over the
last year that's is has just become
incredibly larger in terms of what
people can imagine I mean what what do
what do you think about some of the
stuff that we're doing well right so we
have a lot of new features of course
that we're adding to App Inventor and
we're seeing that the generative AI
craze that's happening uh in the last
year or so has really taken off and
resonated with App Inventor users you
know we have two new components the
chatbot and the imagebot that allow
people to use generative AI as part of
their applications to make question
answering apps to make art apps uh to
really kind of take advantage of these
new Tools in a way that they may not be
able to normally because the technolog
is just too inaccessible it's now become
you know throughout the whole country
throughout the world this idea of
generative Ai and what's being called
the no code
movement and pretty much everybody is
thinking about that and Commercial
implications they're saying who do we
have to hire do they really need to know
programming do they need you know
Computing and it's like the whole world
has expanded but what we're doing now is
we're thinking about that with respect
to kids so all of these ideas of
expansion and access also correspond to
kids and I think for us who' been
thinking about education for so long
there's the question of what what is it
do we want to be teaching in computer
science you know what what is it we want
to teach in terms of programming when
these generative AI programs can can
write WR the programs
themselves and so I think the challenge
for us not only at MIT but throughout
the education world is what does it now
mean to teach people about Computing
when there are just so many
possibilities and so many options you
have you have any favorite examples of
of that uh well certainly you know I
like to kind of compare it to the
evolution of programming Technologies
kind of since the 50s right when you
look at both the evolution of
programming languages and the evolution
of how you program um you know we've
seen a lot of that in terms of used to
punch punch cards and then you had to
write assembly and then you had to write
C and yet the the technology Trends
towards making things easier and more
accessible to folks and with kids in
particular and children we're looking at
you know these are not really difficult
Concepts necessarily that just might
have been presented in a difficult way
and when you put a technology like App
Inventor in front of them they can do
some really amazing things because you
kind of remove that kind of expectation
of complexity that one might have we
talk about coding like oh coding is
really hard well it's not really hard
you just need to think in the right way
to be able to access what the computer
can do and App Inventor is one way of
making it easier for for children to
understand and be able to leverage it
yeah and now the next thing you
mentioned Alexa you know so that's sort
of the next uh advanced piece of tech
that we're doing and the idea of Alexa
is you can just speak a description of
an app and the computer will create the
app you can say uh no build me an app
with a button that has the name of a
language on it and when I press the
button translate what I say into that
language so you literally say that to to
the system and then the system produces
an app that does that right yeah so
we've been working to combine App
Inventor block-based coding language
with generative AI tools like open AIS
GPT models so that yes you can in fact
be able to describe simple applications
with uh you know natural language and
App Inventor is able to create those
apps for you and actually one of the
really neat things I've seen with this
technology is uh we showed it to some of
our power users who are based in the
Netherlands and they gave us app
descriptions in Dutch and the system was
still able to make the app for them and
of course I as an English speaker uh can
look that app and be able to use it uh
because it's a visual programming
language and then with App Inventor
because we offer the language app
inventor language in 14 different Native
languages you know I could look at the
blocks in Chinese I could look at the
blocks in Spanish and I can understand
what the program is doing without
necessarily having to understood the
original description that the user
provided so it's a great way of
collaborating internationally with
people around building applications and
the wild thing is that the thing that's
that's going from spoken language to
building the
app can do it in Dutch even though when
we built it it was in English exactly so
they it's just an example of how
everyone you know even the most advanced
developers here at MIT are constantly
surprised by the power of these things
and now you say what does it mean that
you take that power and you make it
available to kids and to and to everyone
so right now everybody's focused on oh
you can write code but we're going to
the next step we're going it's not only
you write code the code's not there you
just describe what you want and it
builds the
app right so we've got that running with
Appley now in in Prototype but but go
you know who knows what's going to be
next it's really a little bit mind
botling right and so one of the things
we're looking at is how can you make the
applications that app is generating more
complex uh certainly a lot of the early
examples we've taught it with have been
uh you know fairly simple in their
construction they maybe correlate to you
know five to 10 blocks which an App
Inventor is actually a very powerful set
of uh constraints to to work with um and
in those early demos we showed that one
of the really neat features of these
large language models is their ability
to stitch together Concepts from
different programs in order to make more
complex applications and now we're
trying to see if we can take that to the
next level by adding editing capability
into aply so you might get an app it may
not do exactly what you intended for it
to do based on your description but now
you can start to have a conversation
with the computer and say you know hey
could you move that button over to the
right or could you make it bigger or
could you change the color or you know
the behavior is not correct could you
change the code to do X Y and Z and it
can go ahead and actually start to make
those edits on your behalf so even if
you aren't quite sure where uh you can
grab that functionality in the code the
system knows and it can kind of figure
that out for you based on the
instructions you're giving it which
leads you to really being able to build
more and more complex
applications um than the original system
was able to generate which is really
fantastic and so the I mean the the
mindboggling thing is this stuff keeps
getting more and more
powerful and of course our particular
spin at in the MIT App Inventor project
is can we make that power available to
kids yes not just professional programs
but really can anyone do this and I want
to say the is the limit but who knows if
even the sky is the limit in this well I
hope so I mean we we've definitely in in
previous uh collaborations talked about
sending stuff to the International Space
Station so we're hoping to go further
than the sky uh but it is really
fascinating to look at the impact that
App Inventor has had uh over the last 15
years or so where we've had kids
building apps from Eastern Europe to the
Indian some continent we've had people
building apps to help veterans uh after
they leave the service
uh to folks who are building an app for
an individual person who has trouble
speaking and just can't communicate and
so the per you know we had someone who
made an app a retired programmer
actually so they could have built it in
Android Studio or in xcode which are the
Google and Apple products for building
applications but they decided App
Inventor is such an easy way for me to
quickly put together an app to help
somebody that that was their ultimate
decision was I'll just build it an App
Inventor it's so much easier I mean what
you're hinting at is changing not only
for us in education but it's changing
everybody's idea of what programming
should
mean again you just kind of say what you
want and then it gets built and that
sounds
like that that sounds like science
fiction or hand waving but it's really
really starting to happen I think it's
also a bit of a matter of perspective
right when we talk about programming
coding people often go to this vision of
programming and coding is about the
computer but it programming coding are
not about computers they're about humans
it's about what are the problems do I
see in the world and how can I leverage
a computer to solve it but ultimately
you know if it isn't a human impact uh
then you're not really going to be
coding everyone's motivated to code
because they want to solve a problem and
just think about that all being made
possible so one of the really amazing
things about App Inventor and its
relationship with Cale of course is that
at seale we have amazing researchers
building amazing Technologies but those
Technologies are really at the Forefront
of innovation and App Inventor is able
to take those Technologies and represent
them in a way that makes them accessible
to the whole world so that anyone in the
world can make an app that does
something interesting solves a problem
they may see in their community and
ultimately lift this all up and I think
the thing to understand first of all in
terms of advice for teachers it's not
merely that kids can make this stuff
it's that the stuff that kids can make
can now have real impact any uh
14-year-old can put up a datab base
that's accessible to anybody in the
whole world because of internet
technology and so one of the things that
I hope App Inventor is getting across
it's not only that kids can do it but
kids can do serious things that have
real impact and part of that is the way
we've designed the system but part of
that is we've been able to rely on
technology from seale
I you know we said at the beginning that
we have 20 million users I think it's a
million users a month that's not an
obvious thing to be able to put up and
so we're in the wonderful position of
being in a place that really thinks
about education and about even
theoretical computer science but at the
same time has the actual technology to
make this available and that's that's
really what we're working at and I think
teachers need to understand that so it's
not merely that kids can do kind of
interesting things for them it's that if
kids have good enough ideas they can do
something that can impact their city or
their country or anything yeah and you
mentioned uh children being able to make
real positive impact in their
communities it reminds me of a story of
ganali raal who uh as a 13-year-old
heard about the Flint uh Michigan Water
Crisis with lead poisoning that was
basically affecting the people because
of lead in the water and so she made a
device that could detect the uh levels
of lead and built an App Inventor app
around it to be able to read the data
off and visualize it so people could
really see what was going on uh and now
uh full circle she's a student at MIT
the interesting thing about her project
is the thing that impressed people when
she originally did it not so much that
she had the sensors and did the stuff
but she's actually able to make an app
that let people use it so that's become
a little bit uh not not so novel right
now five years later but it really is
that people can use this app technology
to expand what they're doing both in
terms of the the applications they're
allowed to do but in terms of who
they're allowed to make it accessible to
and that's really part of app inventor's
vision